c'est toujours très plaisant de recevoir
un chèque ce gouvernement les aider les
familles en leur envoyant des chèques
pour les torts est ce que c'est vraiment
efficace financièrement
[Musique]
l'équipe de l'aviron s'est posé la
question c'est que monsieur serge blais
de montréal nous a écrit sachant que le
gouvernement du québec va émettre
bientôt un chèque de 100 $ par enfant
pour permettre à leurs parents d'acheter
des fournitures scolaires
monsieur bien se demande combien voir
écouter l'émission de tels chèques et
conviendrait collectivement économiser
ces gouvernements n'étaient pas venus
chercher l'argent dans nos poches
bref si au lieu du chèque on avait tout
simplement baisser les impôts d'abord il
est important de dire que pour l'année
scolaire en cours la mesure est
rétroactive des familles vont recevoir
100 $ par enfant à partir du mois de
janvier en suisse les 100 dollars se
renvoyant juillet soit juste avant la
rentrée scolaire
ceci dit envoyer un chèque coûte à
québec
77 mais le gouvernement on en voit de
moins en moins les québécois
privilégient de plus en plus les
paiements directs
or on reçoit l'argent plus rapidement et
ça coûte beaucoup moins cher à l'état le
paiement direct foot que 400 en sachant
cela on calcule que l'envoi des 100 $
par enfant coûte 100 mille dollars
administré sont les dollars pour une
mesure qui coûte 112 millions de dollars
c'est monsieur bhl est environ 0,1 pour
cent des coûts du programme de crédit
d'impôt
et voici vraiment savoir comment ça cool
d'ajouter une ligne dans le rapport des
cours mais on peut déduire que c'est
moins chers administrés
cependant recevra un chèque ou à cannes
en direct juste avant la rentrée les
parents ont accès à l'argent au moment
d'acheter iphone
avec un crédit d'impôt départ doivent
d'abord débourser pour l'achat des
fournitures scolaires et attendre une
bonne dizaine de mois pour obtenir un
remboursement
c'est se remettre un chèque ou faire un
dépôt direct offre une belle visibilité
au gouvernement en place les odeurs de
la politique
il ya aussi une raison logique de le
faire si comme monsieur blême d'une
question poids sida
[Musique]